Kim is with us in Columbus Georgia hi
Kim how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world basically what our situation is we
have more money going out than we've got
come in on a monthly basis I don't know
weekly basis even and I desperately want
to start this program my husband and
myself we've talked about it and we do
believe this is the way that we'll
finally be able to dig our way out of
this mess that we've gotten ourselves in
but the problem is is I can't pay the
bills that we currently have because
they're so far behind to get caught up
to start saving the thousand dollars for
the first step right and so I just feel
like we I feel like I'm drowning in debt
at this point and I just how long how
long how long have been like this years
[Music]
it's been climbing up yeah and so if you
have maybe between eight to ten years
yeah it's been getting worse but now now
you're getting scared I'm terrified yeah
okay so tell me about the debt how much
do you owe on your cars we don't have
any date on our cars actually we're in a
pretty good place as far as that goes
both our vehicles are paid off what are
they worth and yeah how where they worth
well the saturn's probably only worth if
it's worth 200 I'd be surprised okay
know our drug is the other vehicle and
it's a 2005 so I don't really know what
it's worth to be honest but we do need
both vehicles I wanna hear it I'm not
just trying to figure out if you had a
$30,000 car I was gonna get rid of it
but so what's your in household income
well right now we're looking and
twenty-seven thousand one hundred and
eighty-seven dollars and 32 cents
approximately own what it was what comes
into the home not including these taxes
all that's already I've already figured
that out of it and do you have fun or do
you have any savings coming out of your
checks well this is what I know we
currently don't but I do passed away a
few years ago and she didn't leave us
some money and was that money we were
able to purchase the home that we live
in debt-free that's all we don't have
that over our head thank God that's good
my kids have you got at home I'm sorry
how many children at home myself and a
bunch of dead don't you so what is the
dead on what is your dad on we have
seven credit cards some medical bills
and how much on credit cards hmm well
the credit cards and the medicals
combined I figure we're about 20 end it
that's 20,000 and there's that yes yes I
believe it is I've combed over
everything and tried to the only thing
that this may not include is the our HOA
dues that we are behind them also and
that's probably another thousand okay
all right okay well here's what I'm
hearing you guys are not out there
spending money like crazy people you
don't have any money and so you're not
out there overspending and buying a
bunch of crap because you're out of
control and impulse thing or something
you might at Walmart but you know you're
not you're not doing it big-time
I mean you're not dropping ten grand on
some stupid car you can't afford or
something like that
you've just been you've been dying death
by a thousand cuts a little bit here a
little bit there and
sudden there's 20 ground on a couple
credit cards here and because you've
been out of control for so long and you
don't have any money you know so how
much of a tax refund did you guys get I
think we're getting about 13 total from
both state and federal fouls are a
couple of other factors I want to be
sure that I asked you about 13,000 no
I'm sorry hundred okay I know what you
did now you didn't you said 13 I didn't
know which 13 you were talking about oh
I'm sorry that's all right that's all
right and so that's not a bunch so
you're not being over withheld on taxes
okay let's do two things immediately all
right the first thing we're going to do
is get on a written plan with the money
you have coming into the house okay and
that's a budget jump on every dollar
calm for your phone or for your computer
it's completely free to use it all right
I mean you jump on that you're gonna
make every one of those dollars you and
your husband are both going to sit down
and look at it every month and you're
going to make every dollar behave
because right now you're living crisis
to crisis and you run around putting out
fires and you're not making good
decisions now when you're doing the
written plan that both of you are
agreeing this is the money that comes in
this is where it's going it's not going
any where else okay your first four or
five things you buy or what we call
build the four walls around your house I
want you to make sure your utilities get
current if they're not already your
house is already paid for so you
shouldn't have to worry about that but
you need to catch those HOA dues up and
keep them current anything happened with
food shelter clothing transportation and
utilities so you put gas in the car to
go to work you keep the cars running
that's repairs and insurance and we take
care of the Hou HOA dues because if we
have food we have a place to live we
have a way to drive and we've got
clothing emotionally the rest of it's
just a game
you're behind you're behind in the game
but when you don't know if you've got
enough food money because you gave the
money to credit card company because
they called and yelled at you that gets
you in a different place emotionally you
get the crap scared out of you can't
breathe right and so we take care of the
four walls so you live to fight another
day and then we begin to work through
these other debts so the thing one is a
budget think two is the four walls think
three is I want you to look at your
checks and see if anything is being
taken out of these checks that you can
stop having taken out of your check so
you get more home I want you to get home
with every dollar you can possibly get
home no investing no buying anything
except health insurance only health
insurance nothing else because you're
gonna need the money and then lastly I
want y'all start working on your incomes
because you're living way down next to
poverty level right now your income is
low and that's not calling you out or
calling you a bad name or something I
just want you to make more money because
you need money and so it's a part-time
jobs on the temporary and then this
long-term what are we gonna do it with a
different career as y'all making money
it's hard to do it on twenty seven
thousand it's tough as you've already
found out no kidding Dave I knew that
hang on I'm gonna send you through our
Financial Peace University program and
I'm gonna pay for it hold on